PROFESSOR: Graph coloring
is the abstract version
of a problem that arises from
a bunch of conflict scheduling
situations.
So let's look at an example
first and then define
the problem.
So let's think about a
bunch of aircraft that
have to be scheduled on the
ground at jet ports or gates.
Now, if two flights are on
the ground at the same time,
they need to be assigned
to different gates
since a gate serves
one airplane.
And what we'd like to
do is try to figure out
how many different
gates do we need
to be able to service
all the planes that
might be on the ground.
How many gates are needed?
So let's look at
a sample schedule.
There are six slides here
numbered 122, 145, through 99.
And the horizontal bar is,
say, times during the day.
And this blue block
indicates that flight 122
is on the ground from, let's
say, 3:00 AM to 7:00 AM,
and flight 145 is on the ground
at a completely disjoint time
interval.
So is 67.
257 is on the ground from
midnight until about 6:00 AM.
It does overlap
with 122, and so on.
So this is the
information we have.
And what we're
trying to figure out
is how many gates do we need.
Well, it's easy to see
here that the worst case,
if you just think of this
vertical green line sliding
across the bar, and you
look at the maximum number
of blue intervals that the green
line ever crosses, it's three.
The largest number
of planes that
are on the gate at
any given moment
is three, which means we
can get by with three gates.
So we have to cope
with that conflict.
So abstractly, what
we're going to do
is assign each aircraft
to be a vertex of a graph.
And we're going
to put an edge in
to indicate not
compatibility, but conflict.
Compatibility was what we
were looking at previously
with our examples of matching.
Now this line means
that 306 and 145
are on the ground
at the same time.
They conflict.
They need the same gate,
and we have to serve them
with different gates.
And likewise, 99 and
145 are on the ground.
306 and 99.
And this was the three
flights that were
on the ground at the same time.
And then if I fill in the graph
with all the other vertices
and draw an edge
when two flights are
on the ground at
the same time, I
wind up with this little graph.
OK, now we can talk abstractly
about the coloring problem,
which is let's assign colors
to the vertices in such a way
that no two adjacent
vertices have the same color.
Adjacent vertices should
have different colors.
And it should be clear
from the description of how
we derive this graph from
the aircraft schedules
that the minimum number
of distinct colors
needed to color the
graph corresponds
to the minimum number of gates
needed to serve the aircraft.
So let's try
coloring this graph.
I'll start with
coloring 257 red,
and 122 yellow, and 99 green.
There's no loss
of generality here
because these are
the three that are
on the ground at the same
time, reflected by the fact
that they're in a triangle.
And I'm going to have to
use three different colors
since each one is
adjacent to the other two.
OK, what next?
Well, let's color 145 yellow.
I might as well reuse
it since it's not
adjacent to a yellow vertex.
And then here, I've
got another triangle.
So if I'm not going
to use an extra color,
the sensible thing to do
would be to color that red.
But oops, I didn't do that.
I used a red here.
There's another triangle, I
guess, that allows me to color.
And then I color this black
because here, I'm stuck.
I'm adjacent to both a yellow,
a black, and a green vertex.
So I have to come up
with a fourth color.
All right, we did
it with four colors.
It means that we could have
gotten away with four gates.
And the colors tell
us which aircraft
to assign to which gate.
So 257 and 67 can both be
assigned to the red gate
because they are not on the
ground at the same time.
There's no edge between them.
122 and 145 can be assigned
the yellow gate, and so on.
Now, this was not the
smartest way to color.
A better coloring is shown here.
You can check that every
two adjacent vertices
have different colors.
And now I've done it with only
three colors-- red, yellow,
and green.
So now there are three gates
and I get a better schedule.
Another example of this
kind of conflict problem
comes up with
scheduling final exams.
Two subjects conflict if
a student is taking both.
Because if a
student's taking both,
I can't have the final
exams at the same time.
And so I need to
assign different time
slots during exam period
to subjects that overlap,
that have a student in common.
And then the question is, given
this data about which pairs
of subjects have a
student in common,
we want to know how short
an exam period can we
get away with.
Again, it becomes a simple graph
model and a coloring problem.
So here, we've drawn a graph
with some sample subjects.
6.042 and 18.02 have
a student in common.
That's what that edge means.
They need to have final exam
scheduled at different times.
Likewise, 8.02 and 6.042
have a student in common,
so they need to be scheduled
at different times.
On the other hand,
6.042 and 18.02-- sorry.
What are some two
that are not adjacent?
3.091 and 18.02 have
no edge between them,
which means that they can be
scheduled at the same time.
There's no student who's taking
both 3.091 and 18.02, at least
according to the
data in this graph.
So let's try coloring it.
And again, there's a triangle.
I'm going to have to use
three different colors
for a triangle.
And here's another triangle.
And to be economical,
let's just reuse green.
Now, here, I've
got another vertex
that's adjacent to three
different color vertices.
And so it's going to have to
be colored with a fourth color.
This time, it turns out that the
four colors are best possible.
You can check that.
And it corresponds to a schedule
in which the 6.042 is scheduled
on Monday morning
at 9:00, and 6.001
is scheduled on Monday at 1:00.
But 8.02 and 3.091 can both be
scheduled for Tuesday 9:00 AM.
And finally, 18.02 is scheduled
on Tuesday at 1:00 PM.
OK, so this kind of a
conflict modeling situation
comes up all the time.
Another place where you get
these kind of compatibility
graphs or incompatibility
graphs that you want to color
would be if you
were running a zoo
and you had to have separate
habitats for certain kinds
of species of animals that you
don't want to mix together.
Big fish eat little fish.
It's a truism in
the aquarium world.
And so you need to keep big
fish separate from little fish.
And you don't want the
tigers living together
with the chimpanzees.
So we could again
model this problem
as how many cages do we need.
We create a vertex
for each species
and put an edge between two
species that mustn't share
a habitat or share a cage.
Another one would be assigning
different frequencies
to radio stations.
And again, if two radio stations
are close to each other,
they will interfere.
So they have to be assigned
to different colors
or different frequencies.
So now, we would be using
radio stations as vertices.
And radio stations that were
near enough to interfere
with each other would
get connected by an edge,
indicating that they needed
to be assigned different color
frequencies.
And one of the classic ones
is literally to color a map.
If you were trying to
take, say, a map of the US
and assign colors
to it in such a way
that you never had
two states that
shared a border with the
same color-- and this
is an illustration of
doing it with four colors.
The question is if I give
you some kind of a planar map
like this, what's the
minimum number of colors
that will work?
Now, you're allowed to have
two countries share the color
if they only meet at one point.
But if they have a
positive length boundary,
they have to be
different colors.
OK, the way that this turns
into a vertex coloring problem
is if you take a planar
graph like this-- here's
just an arbitrary
one-- what I can do
is I'm interested in coloring
the regions, the countries,
with different colors,
but I'll just replace
each region by a vertex.
So I'm going to stick a
vertex in the middle of each
of the regions.
Notice there's an outer region
here too that gets a vertex.
So one, two, three, four, five,
six regions, or six vertices.
And then I'll simply
connect two vertices
when there is a positive length
edge that their regions share.
So that edge
corresponds to the fact
that there's this
boundary that's
shared between this
region and this region.
If you look at this same
triangular-shaped region,
it has a boundary with
the outside region.
So there's going to be an edge
from here to the vertex that
represents the outside.
And there's the
rest of the edges.
An edge appears between two
regions that share a boundary.
And now, the question is
coloring the countries
corresponds to
coloring the vertices.
And we'd like to color the graph
with as few colors as possible.
Well, a famous result that
was proved in the '70s
is that every planar graph
is in fact four-colorable.
Now, this was first claimed
to be proved in the 1850s,
but in fact, the
published proof was wrong.
It sat around in the journal
literature for decades
before somebody found a bug.
Or that is to say that the
proof was wrong, not the result.
There was a big hole in
the proof that had not
been adequately justified.
The proof did give a correct
argument for five coloring,
and the four color problem
was opened for over 100 years.
Then in the 1970s,
two mathematicians
came up with a proof of
the four color theorem
that was very controversial
because a lot of their proof
required a computer
program to crank
through several thousand
sample graphs that needed to be
verified for four-colorability.
They had an argument that
showed that there could only
be a few thousand
counter examples if there
was-- or rather, if there
was any graph that couldn't
be four colored, it would be
one of these several thousand
graphs.
And then they went to work on
coloring these several thousand
graphs, which were generated
with the aid of a computer
and then colored with the aid
of a computer, and also by hand.
This did not make the
mathematical community happy
because a proof like that
is essentially uncheckable.
A much improved version
was developed in the 1990s,
but it still
requires, in the end,
a computer program to
generate about 600 maps
and verify their colorability.
So it remains to find a proof
of the four color theorem
that you could say is humanly
comprehensible without the aid
of a computer.
But there's no longer any doubt,
really, about this theorem
in the mathematical community.
In general, if I take
an arbitrary graph
and I ask what's the minimum
number of colors to color it,
that's called the chromatic
number of the graph.
So chi of G is
the minimum number
of colors to color G.
Let's look at some chis
for different kinds of graphs.
So here we have a simple
cycle of length 4.
And it's obvious
that that can be
colored with two colors--
just alternate the colors.
On the other hand,
somewhat-- and in fact,
generalizes, by the way,
to any even length cycle.
The chromatic number of an
even length is simply two.
You color the
vertices alternately.
On the other hand, if the
cycle is of odd length,
you're going to
need a third color.
There's no way around
it because even
if you try to get by
with two colors, then
you color things alternately.
And then when you
wrap around, you
discover that you can't
alternately color.
You're going to need
a third color in order
to avoid a clash.
So in general, the chromatic
number of an odd length cycle
is 3.
The complete graph on five
vertices is shown here.
This is a five vertex
graph in which every vertex
is adjacent to the other four.
And since every vertex is
adjacent to the other four,
you're going to
need five colors.
You can't do any better.
They have to all have
different colors.
And so the chromatic number
of the complete graph
on n vertices where
every vertex is
adjacent to the
other n minus 1 is n.
Another simple example that
comes up is if I take the cycle
and I put on an
axle in the middle--
we call it a wheel then.
A wheel with a cycle of length
of 5 around the outside,
a perimeter of length
5, is called W5.
And we can color it
with four colors.
And in general, the argument
that the chromatic number
for an odd length
wheel is four is
that I know I'm going to need
three colors to color the rim.
And since the axle is adjacent
to everything on the rim,
I'm going to need a
fourth color for it.
On the other hand, again,
if the perimeter is even,
then I can get by
with three colors.
One more remark about
chromatic numbers
is there's an easy
argument that shows
that if you have a graph,
every one of whose vertices is
at most degree k-- there
are at most k other vertices
adjacent to any given
vertex-- then that
implies that the graph
is k plus 1 colorable.
And the proof is really
constructive and trivial.
Basically, you just start
coloring the vertices any way
you like subject
to the constraint
that when you color
a vertex, it's
supposed to not be
the same color as any
of the vertices around it.
But that's easy to do.
Because when it's time
to color some vertex,
even if all the vertices
around it are colored,
there's only k of them.
And so I will always be able
to find a k plus first color
to assign it and get us
a satisfactory coloring.
So I can get by with
k plus 1 colors.
Now, the general setup
with colorability
is that to check whether
a graph is two-colorable
is actually very easy.
And we may talk about that
in some class problems.
But three-colorability
dramatically changes.
We're back in the realm
of NP-complete problems.
In fact, a result
of a student of mine
almost 40 years ago was that
even if a graph is planar
where you know it can definitely
be colored with four colors,
determining whether
or not it can
be colored with three colors
is as hard as satisfiability.
And it is, in fact, an
NP-complete problem.
In fact, a proof of how
you reduce satisfiability
to colorability
appears in a problem
in the text, which we may
assign as a problem set problem.
So in general, finding chi of G
is hard, even for three colors.
Now, it's not any worse,
again, from a theoretical point
of view for checking
what chi of G
is even if it's a very large
number, although pragmatically,
three color will be easier
to check than n-colorability.
And that is our story
about colorability.